the metropolitan police made an arrest
in a juca bar shooting
last weekend how are you greeted by
cristian casares the
44 year old suspect books in appeared in court on
thursday he faces one charge of
murder and 12 charges of attempted
murder detectives expect to make
more arrests in the wake of the violent
altercation that left one person dead
and 13 others injured
Saturday morning at the menis glow after
work bar near streets yesterday and
merlin online
meanwhile the man whom
authorities call the verb ver de
rainbow also had its day in court at the
site where he faces twelve charges of
theft in a series of incidents that took
place from December
to February according to the
arrest report at least nine businesses were
robbed  crimes started in
grocery stores but then
escalated to
banks war abroad is
impacting prices here at
home inflation s  keeps rising so
the federal reserve is monitoring the
crisis in ukraine the world was already facing
a shortage of supplies and
rising inflation but today the
triple 'a' agency reports that the
national average price for a gallon of
gasoline is reaching almost a  dollar
more than last year the average cost
nationwide registers three
dollars and 72 cents while here in the
state of nevada the average has already
exceeded 4 dollars so the
federal reserve has plans to start
a series of interest increases  this
month
and a sunny day is expected with
temperatures of almost 80 degrees
seize the day because the cold will
return snow is expected in the
mountains during the next few days with
temperatures of 60 degrees here in the
valley I am cristian casseres with his brief
information  from news now in spanish good
day
[Music]